monsieur le rapporteur général
madame la rapporteur spécial madame la
Présidente Mesdames Messieurs chers
collègues nous procédons donc
aujourd'hui une audition pour suite à
donner à l'enquête de la Cour des
comptes réalisées à la demande de notre
commission en application du deuxième
monde de l'article 58 de la loi
organique relative aux lois de finance
sur l'adaptation du parc nucléaire au
changement climatique
l'impact environnemental nucléaire et
son rôle dans la lutte contre le
changement climatique font l'objet de
nombreux débats c'est rien de le dire
cependant la question inverse est
beaucoup moins posée quelles sont les
conséquences du changement climatique
sur la production d'électricité et la
sûreté nucléaire la canicule de l'été
dernier qui a failli conduire à l'arrêt
de plusieurs centrales sur notre
territoire montre qu'il s'agit là d'un
enjeu majeur c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous nous interroge aujourd'hui
sur les modalités d'adaptation du parc
clair français et les coûts
d'investissement que celle-ci représente
nous recevons donc Madame annippoder
présidente de la deuxième chambre de la
codécompte qui nous présentera les
principales conclusions de l'enquête
réalisée par les magistrats de la Cour
pour nous éclairer sur le sujet et
répondre aux observations de la Cour et
du rapporteur spécial
sont également présents monsieur Rémy
Catteau directeur des centrales
nucléaires à l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire la SN ainsi que Madame
Catherine Albas
directrice je dis toutes sur la
prononciation m'excuserez mais vous le
corrigerez la directrice du projet adapt
à la direction production nucléaire et
thermique à EDF
après avoir entendu madame Podeur notre
collègue Christine Lavarde en sa qualité
de rapporteur spécial présentera les
principaux enseignements qu'elle tirent
de cette enquête à l'issue du débats je
demanderai aux membres de la commission
des finances leur accord pour publier
l'enquête remise par la Cour des comptes
je rappelle à chacun que cette audition
est retransmise sur le site internet du
Sénat ceci étant dit je laisse tout de
suite la parole à Madame manipoder
peut-être pour une vingtaine de minutes
si elle le veut bien
2 x 3 monsieur le Président
Mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs mesdames messieurs vous nous
avez saisi monsieur le Président par
lettre du 18 janvier 2022 de cette
demande d'enquête sur l'adaptation en
changement climatique du parc des
réacteurs nucléaires nous vous en
remercions et c'est un honneur
d'ailleurs de pouvoir présenter devant
vous aujourd'hui les principales
conclusions de nos travaux que vous avez
d'ailleurs parfaitement introduit et je
vous enseignerai je vais rappeler
brièvement le contexte et l'objet du
rapport avant de vous présenter parce
que c'est l'essentiel nos principaux
constats et recommandations
ce rapport fait suite à plusieurs
travaux de la Cour des comptes sur le
nucléaire civil je cite Laval du cycle
du combustible nucléaire la règle des
mentalement des installations et
nucléaires déjà à la demande du Sénat on
vous en servez là aussi et plus
récemment la filière européenne cette
nouvelle enquête a donné lieu à
plusieurs échanges avec Madame
latinatrice Christine lavard rapporteur
spécial au début en milieu d'enquête et
enfin pour la restitution et je la
remercie de sa disponibilité
l'instruction s'est déroulée entre
février et octobre 2002 avec deux
visites sur site importante la centrale
de Nogent-sur-Seine et le Centre de
recherche du groupe EDF à Chatou pour
les personnes rencontrées je vous
renvoie à l'annexe ça peut toujours être
utile pour vous
la contradiction s'est déroulée novembre
et décembre 2022 elle a été très riche
très intéressante le projet de
communication a été délibéré le 18
janvier 2023 au sein de la deuxième
chambre puis valider le 31 janvier 2023
par le comité du rapport public et des
programmes c'est enquête s'inscrit dans
un contexte particulier dont je rappelle
les tressaillants d'abord une prise de
conscience des impacts du changement
climatique prise de conscience accélérée
sans doute à la suite du sixième rapport
du GIEC publié début 2022 mais surtout à
la suite de l'été 2022 avec ses épisodes
caniculaires deuxième élément de
contexte important l'annonce du
président de la République à Belfort au
mois de février 2022 d'un plan de
relance du nucléaire c'est quand même un
élément
fondamental et parallèlement troisième
élément très factuel une baisse
historique de la production nucléaire en
2022 compte tenu des arrêt pour contrôle
de la sûreté lié au défaut de corrosion
sous contrainte et d'ailleurs récemment
on a encore découvert une nouvelle
fissure sur Paris qui nécessite à
nouveau des réexamens y compris par
l'ASN et qui reporte la remise en
exploitation des éléments d'actualité
législatives j'en veux pour preuve
d'ailleurs que votre assemblée a adopté
en première lecture le 24 janvier
dernier le projet de loi relatif à
l'accélération des procédures liées à la
construction des nouvelles installations
nucléaires et nous nous préparons dans
le cas de la future stratégie française
énergies climat la fameuse fête à ce que
vous examiniez vous une loi de
programmation énergique climat qui sera
suivie de la nouvelle stratégie
nationale bas carbone du nouveau plan
d'adaptation en changement climatique et
de la nouvelle programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie tout ça va
s'enchaîner dans les 24 mois à venir
autre élément
introductif alors plus de fond cette
fois
des conséquences du changement
climatique vont affecter et affectent
déjà à des degrés divers mais croissants
les réacteurs du parc national actuel
mais je le dis un peu surnellement
l'affectera encore plus les projets de
construction des nouveaux réacteurs
susceptibles d'entrer en service à
partir de 2035 alors comment se
manifeste ce changement climatique sur
les réacteurs et bien on a distingué
finalement trois cercles concentriques
ça affecte d'abord les installations
elles-mêmes et leurs capacité à
fonctionner de façon sûre
notamment sur la résistance des
matériels des équipements mais également
faut pas l'oublier la compatibilité avec
des conditions de travail acceptables
pour les personnels sur site deuxième
cercle concentrique environnement
extérieur proche en lien avec
l'exploitation et la sûreté il s'agit du
débit et de la température des cours
d'eau mais également du niveau de la mer
pour l'essentiel puis enfin troisième
cercle des conséquences plus
périphériques comme le risque accru
d'incendie de forêt ou de végétation ou
encore le risque de submersion d'axe
routiers à proximité des centrales nous
avons analysé les deux premiers cercles
en revanche les risques affectant la
périphérie des centrales ne sont pas
traitées dans cette enquête parce qu'il
nécessitait d'autres travaux spécifiques
mais nous y reviendrons dans des
rapports apparaître mais en tout cas
nous insistons sur la nécessité d'une
approche intégrée et territorialisée
pour faire face à l'ensemble des
conséquences du changement climatique
dernière mention sur le périmètre le
rapport concerne
exclusivement le parc de production
nucléaire actuelle à l'exclusion des
réacteurs de recherche du CEA des
installations militaires de même que les
installations nucléaires qui sont
relatives à la fabrication du
combustible sont retraitement ou encore
le stockage des matières et des déchets
radioactifs toujours au nombre des
rappels introductifs on plante un peu le
décor le parc nucléaire actuel est
composé de 18 centrales qui regroupent
56 réacteurs à hauts pressurisés en
exploitation d'une puissance comprise
entre 900 mégawatts et 1400 MW selon les
paliers pour une puissance totale
installée de
61,4 gigawatt pour être un peu concret
il y en a 13 centrales en bord de
rivière 4 centrales en bord de mer une
centrale en bordestuaire en tout cas ce
parc tel qu'il existe actuellement et
très dépendant de la des sources en eau
je rappelle parce que c'est le moyen de
refroidir refroidir les réacteurs il
existe d'ailleurs deux types de systèmes
de refroidissement à circuit ouvert et à
circuit fermé pour la bonne
compréhension de tous je définis un peu
ces concepts en circuit ouvert l'eau
prélevée est utilisée pour refroidir le
réacteur puis rejeter dans son milieu
les prélèvements sont donc très
importants mais la consommation nette en
eau et finalement très faible les rejets
augmentent en revanche la température
des cours d'eau c'est une mention
importante en circuit fermé maintenant
ça concerne exclusivement des réacteurs
en bord de fleurs il y en a 30 qui sont
concernés la quantité d'eau prélevée
circule dans
l'aéroréfrigérant donc la quantité
prélevée est beaucoup plus faible mais
il y a une évaporation qu'on évalue à
24%
c'était l'évaluation en 2001 s'agissant
de l'avenir maintenant je rappelle que
le Président de la République a annoncé
la construction d'une première tranche
ferme de 6 EPR 2 de 1650 MW puis d'une
deuxième tranche en option de 8 paires 2
en Suisse évidemment de l'EPR de
Flamenville dont nous attendons toujours
la mise en service voilà
le présent rapport est structuré très
simplement deux chapitres le premier
présente les enjeux climatiques auxquels
doit faire face le parc nucléaire actuel
et l'organisation mise en place par EDF
donc c'est un chapitre très contextuel
le second en revanche examine très
concrètement comment les dispositifs de
sûreté nucléaire prennent en compte le
changement climatique puis analyse les
contraintes que fait peser la
disponibilité de la sans eau sur
l'exploitation du parc et enfin
identifie les risques qui affectent les
projets de construction des futurs
réacteurs pour reprendre les points
majeurs du rapport je vous propose de
retenir 7 grands constats j'illustrerai
chaque constat par une ou plusieurs
diapositives de pas plus et ensuite je
mentionnerai les recommandations à qui
s'y rattache alors comment appréhender
le changement climatique ce qui est
certain c'est que pour le parc actuel la
perspective de prolongation de la durée
de vie jusqu'à 60 ans qui semble
prévaloir aujourd'hui
fera fonctionner le parc jusqu'au tour
de 2045 ce qu'il l'expose non seulement
aux aléas climatiques actuelles mais
aussi à leur accentuation au cours des
20 à 30 prochaines années par
comparaison les futurs réacteurs dont la
durée d'exploitation pourrait aller
jusqu'en 21 voir au-delà seront très
directement confrontés aux conséquences
plus lourdes du changement climatique
une forte augmentation des températures
une fréquence accrue d'événements
climatiques extrêmes une diminution des
débits moyens et des étiages des fleuves
et une élévation potentiellement
importante du niveau de la mer alors
compte tenu de ces éléments le premier
constat que nous faisons c'est qu'idef
qui est le seul exploitant s'appuie
fortement sur les travaux du GIEC en
particulier ces cinquième et 6e rapport
et que cette appui est partagé par
l'ensemble des acteurs du nucléaire en
France c'est compléter évidemment par
les modèles de Météo France pour la
France et les travaux de l'Institut
Pierre Simon Laplace que nous nous
sommes efforcés du vulgariser et de
mentionner dans la première partie du
rapport
sur les cinq scénarios du GIEC
IDF exclut le scénario le plus optimiste
analyse plus particulièrement le
scénario les plus pessimistes ce qui est
d'ailleurs cohérent pour des
installations à très longue durée de vie
et mentionne également le scénario
médian qui est considéré c'est normal
comme le plus probable
finalement il reste que ces études et
ses projections climatiques sur une
échelle de temps très longue qui sont
donc les travaux du GIEC et les modèles
développés sont peu adaptés aux
échéances beaucoup plus proches 10 à 15
ans qui sont pourtant celles utilisées
par les squant pour décider et calibrer
des investissements nouveaux lors de
chacune des visites décennales des
réacteurs et la cour pointe que c'est
une des difficultés rencontrées par EDF
pour adapter le parc actuel dans une
logique économique qui soit optimisée
deuxième constat parmi les multiples
conséquences probables du changement
climatique je vous l'ai dit la
disponibilité de la ressource en eau
représente sans surprise le principal
enjeu pour le parc nucléaire en fait le
volume d'eau douce prélevé pour
satisfaire les différents usages de la
population s'élève chaque année à 33
milliards de mètres cubes un peu plus de
la moitié je dis bien un peu plus de la
moitié de ce volume prélevé et destiné
au refroidissement des centrales
électronucléaires bien évidemment c'est
pas de la consommation nette puisqu'elle
restitue
98% c'est à dire la quasi-totalité de
ces prélèvements au milieu naturel à
proximité du point de prélèvement mais
je l'ai déjà mentionné et c'est une un
point important à une température plus
élevée
dès lors les enjoliers la ressource en
eau prennent des formes différentes
selon qu'il s'agisse des cours d'eau ou
des littoraux pour les centrales en bord
de cours d'eau ils sont multiples et ils
vont aller croissants la moindre
disponibilité de la ressource en eau va
accentuer les conflits d'usage notamment
avec l'agriculture mais aussi le
tourisme d'autres industries et parfois
avec la navigation le réchauffement des
fleuves en amont et en aval des
centrales va représenter une contrainte
d'exploitation supplémentaire et enfin
les niveaux d'étiages vont réduire la
capacité de dilution des rejets en aval
des centrales ce sont des contraintes
lourdes pour les centrales en bord de
mer en fait l'enjeu n'est pas l'accès à
la ressource en eau parce qu'il est
évident mais il s'agit au contraire de
faire face à la montée du niveau marin
et au risque de submersion qui en
découlent il s'agit d'un des phénomène
plus lent mais qui concernera surtout
les futurs centrales situés en littoral
dans la seconde moitié du 21e siècle
troisième enjeu et troisième constat les
politiques et les organisations mises en
place d'une part par l'État d'autre part
par EDF à bord de bien la question de
l'adaptation du parc nucléaire au
changement climatique le sujet est donc
bien identifié ce n'est pas le cas pour
tous les secteurs de l'action publique
mais de la prise de conscience à la
traduction opérationnelle il faut un
petit peu de temps et on en est encore
au balbutiements pour ce qui concerne
l'état le premier plan national
d'adaptation en changement climatique
comportait 200 recommandations c'est à
2011-2015 plusieurs portaient sur
l'énergie l'industrie et incluait les
centrales nucléaires vous n'allez pas
très loin pourtant les travaux de gens
je vous aime qui avaient une mission
particulière avait permis de mettre à
disposition des données climatiques
détaillées propres à la France et
décliner au niveau régional pour ce qui
concerne les f les Direction de la
recherche et du développement s'est
engagé dès 1990 je redis bien 1990 dans
plusieurs travaux autour du changement
climatique donc vraiment une prise de
conscience précoce mais ce n'est que
plus récemment en 2014 qui EDF a créé un
service climatique en appui des
principales direction concernée du
groupe et depuis l'an dernier les EDF
met en place mais en oeuvre un plan
d'adaptation en changement climatique
modifiables tous les 5 ans concrètement
la direction de la production nucléaire
est thermique et représentée élaborée un
projet adapt à décliné dans chaque
centrage
chaque centrale nucléaire et la
direction ingénierie et projet du
nouveau nucléaire intègre également dans
la conception une analyse de l'impact de
potentiel du changement climatique donc
il y a des progrès il y a une prise de
conscience il y a des moyens mis en
oeuvre et des méthodes mises en oeuvre
il manque encore et nous le soulignons
une approche de l'adaptation plus
intégrée plus territorialisée qui soit
vraiment partagée entre tous les acteurs
du nucléaire en particulier
l'état l'ASN les RSN avec l'exploitant
EDF nous y reviendrons plus tardivement
quatrième constat les effets du
changement climatique sont pris en
compte au titre de la sûreté c'est un
point important et c'est ce point par
lequel nous commençons en fait la
conception initiale des centrales
aujourd'hui en fonctionnement sont
antérieurs à l'émergence même de la
notion de changement climatique mais les
aléas climatiques étaient alors
appréhendées à travers la notion
d'agression externe naturelle comme les
températures de l'air et de l'eau les
inondations les étiages d'ailleurs les
importantes marges retenues à la
conception de ces centrales pour la
résistance à ces phénomènes ont de fait
permis d'intégrer les évolutions
climatiques progressivement néanmoins
nous avons
pris en compte l'évolution climatique
comme un élément clé de la sûreté elle
est désormais intégrée dans les
référentiels imposés par l'autorité
sûreté qui s'agisse des intégrations
dans le cadre du grand froid au pour des
années 80 des inondations après
l'accident du Blayais en 1999 ou encore
du référentiel grand show après la
canicule de 2003
l'accidente Fukushima en 2011 et les
évaluations sur tes complémentaires ont
conduit à renforcer encore ses
référentiels et à les mettre à jour à
chaque visite décennale ainsi intégrer
dans les démonstrations sûreté et
régulièrement évaluer on peut considérer
que les risques qu'emportent le
changement climatique ne doivent pas
affecter le niveau de sûreté du parc
nucléaire
d'ailleurs cinquième constat le coût
estimé de cette adaptation au changement
climatique
demeure extrêmement modeste en termes
d'investissement alors il faut dire que
EDF ne l'a pas évalué complètement et
précisément parce que faut en convenir
aussi à leur décharge un même
investissement peut concomitamment
relever de la sûreté et de l'adaptation
en changement climatique je viens d'en
faire la démonstration en vous exposant
la prise en compte de la sûreté pour
autant l'entreprise a réussi quand même
après moult recherche à nous indiquer
que les investissements relatifs au
climat et à la météo comme la rénovation
d'aéro-réfrigérant la construction et le
rehaussement de digue représente un
montant d'investissement déjà réalisé de
960 millions d'euros donc à peine un
milliard sur la période
2006-2021 donc à peine un milliard sur
15 ans
les dépenses
programmées en lien avec l'adaptation
changement climatique sur la période à
venir 2022 2038 s'élèverait à environ
612 millions d'euros en fonctionnement
alors là c'est l'épaisseur du trait
puisque quand on ajoute les budgets du
service climatique le programme adapte
les actions de recherche développement
dédiés à l'adaptation on arrive comme en
témoigne le tableau 5 en page 41 à moins
de 5 millions d'euros par an
ce ne sont donc pas de lourds enjeux
financiers pour autant et nous y
insistons il nous semble nécessaire que
EDF puis justifier dans l'avenir des
coûts d'adaptation au changement
climatique de sa performance sur ce
point à la fois au titre de sa
responsabilité
sociale et environnementale comme de ses
obligations une communication financière
et extra-financière et c'est le sens de
notre recommandation numéro 1 je
n'arrive au sixième constat sur la
production maintenant en fait faut
convenir que le changement climatique et
notamment les épisodes plus fréquents de
sécheresse et de canicule peuvent
altérer la disponibilité du parc
nucléaire ces effets sont aujourd'hui
limités mais vont croissants il résulte
de deux contraintes de production d'une
part l'application des normes
environnementales pour protéger les
milieux aquatiques et d'autre part
l'application des accords
transfrontaliers qui dans certains cas
la capacité de prélèvement les pertes de
production qui résultent des normes
environnementales demeure à ce jour
limitée en moyenne annuelle de l'ordre
de 1% avec un pic à un 4 % au cours de
l'année 2003 les sites concernés par ces
pertes de production sans ce qu'on
appelle dans notre jargon ou dans le
jargon DDF des sites thermosensibles
c'est à dire des sites sensibles aux
limites de température en bord de
rivière ou d'estuaire il s'agit de
Saint-Alban de tricassin du budget de
Blayais et de Golfech les pertes de
production liées aux contraintes de
prélèvement notamment par les accords
transfrontaliers sont concentrés sur la
centrale de chaux très sensible au débit
de la Meuse et soumise à l'application
du fameux accord transfrontalier avec la
Belgique dès lors les pertes
d'opportunités économique qui résulte de
ces pertes de production sont également
limitées mais
demain il ces indisponibilités sont
concentrées certes sur des périodes
brèves estivales mais de plus en plus
longues et elles peuvent s'avérer
critiques en accroissant les riches de
tension sur le réseau alors exposé à une
demande accrue d'électricité sur tout
dans un contexte d'électrification
majeure des usages en outre au cours de
ces dernières années une augmentation
significative des arrêts pour cause
climatiques a été constaté sur certains
sites avec des pertes si elles vont à
plusieurs terawatters par an les études
prospectives mettent en évidence une
multiplication par un facteur de 3 à 4
des indisponibilités liées au
réchauffement climatique à échéance de
2050 donc dans les décennies qui
viennent ça peut être
icatif
dès lors pour gérer au mieux ses risques
de moindre production trois
recommandations d'abord mieux connaître
l'évolution du débit des fleuves à
échéance de quelques années ce que les
projections climatiques actuelles ne
permettent pas de bien appréhender il
faut aussi qu'en période de faible débit
l'exploitant puisse disposer d'une plus
forte capacité d'entreposage des
effluents liquides dans l'attente de
pouvoir les rejeter sans risque dans
l'environnement c'est constats
conduisent à la recommandation 2 du
rapport il s'agit également
c'est la recommandation 3 de consolider
et de mettre à jour les fondements
scientifiques qui justifient les limites
réglementaires des rejets thermiques
dont la fixation sera d'autant plus
sensible que les épisodes chauds se
multiplieront fait très longtemps qu'on
n'a pas réinterroger
ses limites réglementaires je pense que
ça doit être fait de manière concerté
enfin pour la cour il s'agit pour EDF de
renforcer son effort de recherche sur
les systèmes de refroidissement afin de
limiter la consommation en eau et
l'emploi de réactif chimique ensuite
rejeté dans le million naturel et c'est
l'invitation à la sobriété en tout genre
ce qui fait l'objet de la recommandation
numéro 4 en fait en matière de recherche
on observe qu'il y a beaucoup
d'innovations émergentes mais aucune
innovation technique notable n'a été
mise en œuvre sur le parc existant pour
limiter la consommation en eau et DF
nous a simplement indiqué avoir réalisé
en 2022 une analyse préliminaire d'un
procédé de récupération d'eau des
panaches d'aéro-réfrigérants et la mise
en place d'un démonstrateur de ce
procédé qui
interviendrait à partir de 202 3 sur le
site du budget nous arrivons au septième
et dernier constat qui concerne le
nouveau nucléaire
j'insiste les futurs réacteurs seront
soumis à des exigences beaucoup plus
fortes au regard du changement
climatique et il faut considérer que
cette dernière partie
est une forme d'alerte adressée à
l'ensemble des acteurs du nucléaire
d'abord pour souligner qu'il existe à
travers le monde des réacteurs qui
fonctionnent sous des climats très
chauds comparables sans doute aux
épisodes que notre pays pourrait
connaître dans la seconde moitié du 21e
siècle
ces centrales fonctionnent avec des
dispositifs adaptés comme celle de Palo
Verde et il nous semble que ces
expériences pourraient être utiles
[Musique]
par ailleurs on parle d'installer des
SMS alors j'ai utilisé une expression
française petit réacteur modulaire
en complément du programme de PR2 et
bien écoutez il conviendrait sans
attendre de prendre en compte justement
les contraintes du changement climatique
dès la conception de ce type
d'équipement sachant que la mise au
point d'un premier démonstrateur serait
envisageable d'après les indications
dont nous disposons à horizons 10 ans
mais surtout pour les EPR 2 alors nous
soulignons dans le rapport que leur
conception intègre bien des marges de
sécurité face au changement climatique
et que cette conception s'appuie sur une
analyse précise des référentiels de
sûreté en vigueur qui serait donc
incrémenté tant de la part des DF que de
la SM c'est positif pour autant la Cour
a constaté premièrement que les EPR 2 ne
comportent pas d'évolution technologique
marquée en particulier de système de
refroidissement sobre en eau
deuxièmement qu'il n'est pas tenu compte
de l'hypothèse certes estimée peu
probable par le GIEC d'une fonte des
calottes glaciaires ce qui provoquerait
une hausse plus élevée du niveau de la
mer or cette hypothèse extrême pourrait
peser sur le choix des sites littoraux
et sur la façon surtout d'engager de
futurs chantiers
troisièmement et j'y reviens donc sur
cette question limitaire qu'il manque
encore sur ces questions d'adaptation
une approche qui soit réellement
intégrée et commune à l'ensemble des
acteurs directement concernés d'où la
recommandation 5 qui
appelle de ses vœux cette approche
intégrée commune et qui soit sur tout
territorialisé et concrète parce que
lorsque j'abordais les trois cercles
concentriques bien évidemment chaque
site a sur ce point c'est particularités
et on ne peut pas rester à un niveau
exclusivement conceptuel et national
enfin le rapport constate que pour les 8
EPR en option et bien EDF n'envisage pas
de site nouveau mais n'exclu non plus à
ce stade aucun des sites en exploitation
si les normales que le choix décide
d'écoule une analyse multicritaire et
notamment de la prise en compte de
préoccupation d'aménagement du
territoire il nous semble que les
incidences du changement climatique pour
des réacteurs qui fonctionneront pour
l'essentiel lors de la seconde moitié du
21e siècle et bien sa justifie de
produire rapidement des études de prix
faisabilité qui prennent en compte le
changement climatique c'est l'objet de
la sixième et dernière recommandation
adressée à la fois à EDF et au ministère
chargé de la transition écologique
à la fin de cette présentation très
condensée j'ai peut-être dépassé les 20
minutes monsieur le Président et je vous
remercie d'accepter mes excuses vous
aurez compris en tout cas que
l'adaptation en changement climatique
des réacteurs nucléaires n'est pas un
enjeu financier c'est un défi
d'anticipation surtout à l'heure où
notre pays s'engage sur le projet
ambitieux du nouveau nucléaire et ça
nécessite une coordination renforcée des
principaux acteurs à la fois à l'échelon
national mais surtout sur chaque site de
production et sur les chantiers à venir
pour définir des réponses communes
nous espérons en tout cas que ce travail
pourra utilement éclairé vos propres
réflexions en tout cas il nous a conduit
à la cour à un exercice inhabituel
puisque nous sommes pas limités à une
approche financière mais que nous avons
tenté une synthèse scientifique et que
nous avons essayé d'appréhender au mieux
avec le concours d'ailleurs des
principaux acteurs les enjeux techniques
qui
définissent cette appréhension du
changement climatique je vous remercie
de votre attention et me tient avec
l'équipe de contrôle à votre disposition
merci madame la Présidente je vais
demander maintenant à Christine Lavarde
rapporteur spécial ou dire quels
enseignements ils tirent de cette
présentation merci monsieur le Président
donc effectivement je vais rebondir sur
les propos de conclusion de madame la
Présidente et pour ceux qui ont lu le
rapport vous avez pu voir
qu'effectivement ça a un rapport qui
sort un peu des sentiers
usuels de la cour puisque effectivement
il est moins temps question d'enjeux
financiers que d'enjeux de technologie
et de réflexion sur le long terme et la
photographie qui est faite aujourd'hui
de notre parc nucléaire il me semble
qu'elle présente deux aspects qui sont
liés au réchauffement climatique et aux
modifications à notre environnement la
question des événements
on va dire exceptionnel parce que d'une
ampleur exceptionnelle et cela en fait
dès l'origine de la construction des
centrales nucléaires ont déjà été pris
en compte et on a des normes de
résistance au vent des bâtiments de
construction à un seuil au-delà du
niveau de la mer enfin qui ont déjà été
en fait intégrés les centrales nos
centrales elles sont prêtes à résister à
des événements extrêmes dont la
probabilité de survenance parfois en
France est inférieure à 1 sur 10
millièmes typiquement capable de
résigner de résister pardon un ami de
type de celui de Fukushima alors que la
probabilité d'avoir un tsunami en France
c'est quand même assez faible donc sur
cet aspect sûreté on est prêt là où on
est peut-être un peu moins près en fait
c'est pour les événements qui sont avec
un temps long et il y a peu de temps je
vous parlais du retrait gonflement des
argiles et en fait l'événement là
aujourd'hui qui va directement concerner
les centrales nucléaires c'est celui de
l'élévation des températures
et qui dit en fait élévation des
températures vient effectivement poser
des questions sur la disponibilité de la
ressource en eau nécessaire pour faire
fonctionner le cycle nucléaire et
d'ailleurs cette question elle pose un
certain nombre aussi d'interrogations
pour les gestionnaires du parc et
typiquement EDF qui peut se retrouver
dans des situations à devoir procéder à
des arbitrages entre faire de la
production hydraulique ou garder l'eau
de manière à pouvoir avoir un éthias
suffisant dans les cours d'eau ensuite
pour assurer une production nucléaire
donc c'est à dire que là un moment il
faudra faire un choix est-ce qu'on veut
effectivement avoir une on est sur une
production qui est décarbonée dans les
deux cas avec une qui est 100% verte on
va dire et en tout cas qui répond aux
enjeux de la taxonomie européenne et une
autre qui est encore dans les marges de
cette taxonomie et donc voilà il faudra
faire et ce qui n'est pas le même coup
après pour l'électricité produite en
tout cas sur le volume d'électricité
produit donc là c'est ce type de
réflexion aussi et ce type de choix que
va devoir faire le gestionnaire
d'infrastructures mais pour faire ces
choix là il n'est pas seul c'est aussi
un choix qui appartiendra il me semble
au politique et effectivement cette
question de la de la gestion et de la
ressource en eau elle ouvre aussi un
nouveau champ d'interrogation qui surgit
là en ce moment on voit bien que nos
nappes phréatiques commencent à être un
niveau très bas qui est celui de la
réutilisation des eaux usées qui
aujourd'hui est proche de zéro en France
et typiquement le fonctionnement de la
centrale de Palo Verde qui est bien
décrite dans le rapport on voit qu'on
c'est une Centrale qui se refroidit en
utilisant les eaux usées alors après ça
nécessitait tout un une infrastructure
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui nous on est prêt à
avoir des canalisations très longues
pour venir on n'est pas dans le même
contexte là on a une Centrale qui est
dans le désert aujourd'hui il y a aucun
endroit en France en tout cas qui
pourrait avoir mais ça ouvre quand même
des perspectives sur aussi une autre
utilisation possible des eaux usées qui
pourraient avoir à ce moment-là un enjeu
en de production de production d'énergie
ce que je retiens aussi de ces apports
de la cour c'est effectivement tout
l'enjeu de réfléchir à demain et l'enjeu
de d'accès d'accentuer en fait les
moyens publics sur la recherche pour
venir diminuer l'empreinte
environnementale du nucléaire au-delà de
la question du retraitement des déchets
qui est vraiment extérieur à l'objet du
contrôle mais typiquement pour venir
diminuer l'utilisation de biocide pour
le fonctionnement des tours
aéroréfrigérantes pour venir peut-être
essayer d'améliorer le rendement
justement de ces tours aéroréfrigérantes
puisqu'on comprend bien quand même qu'il
y a 30%, il y a une déperdition à cette
chaleur qui s'échappe sous forme de
fumée est-ce que demain elle pourrait
pas être utilisée pour justement revenir
faire de l'énergie sous une autre forme
et je voudrais pas ouvrir un débat qui
est en dehors mais qui est un petit peu
en lien notamment dans l'amendement qui
avait été déposé par le Gouvernement
dans le texte sur le nucléaire sur la
fusion entre l'IRSN et la SN moi il me
semble que la question des CAP profiter
de recherche de l'URSS n'avait pas été
abordé et ça c'est un sujet qui est
vraiment au cœur de ce dont on discute
cet après-midi et enfin pour finir et
pour dire que je souscris complètement
à la recommandation de la cour en tout
cas au constat de la cour de dire que ce
sujet il doit être pris dans une de
manière
systémique et moi j'ai envie de dire
passe une pas uniquement sur
l'environnement proche de la centrale
c'est-à-dire l'été les terrains qui sont
autour d'elle pour savoir s'il faut les
préenter de manière à demain pouvoir
faire construire une digue ou autre en
cas de mais aussi pour se dire que
aujourd'hui la chaîne du nucléaire il
faut pouvoir construire les
installations il faut pouvoir extraire
du combustible extraire du combustible
et autres entraîne aussi des
conséquences de prélèvement de la
ressource qui ont des conséquences sur
notre environnement qui vont aussi
demain de voir répondre aux injonctions
de l'Union européenne notamment avec la
directive sur le devoir de vigilance
donc c'est là où je pense qu'il y a
matière à poursuivre ses travaux pour
essayer de penser toute la chaîne de de
production du nucléaire et finalement le
travail qui a été fait aujourd'hui sur
ce point de notre économie je pense va
pouvoir être dupliqué demain dans
d'autres champs où on va se rendre
compte qu'il y a des conflits d'usage
entre les ressources environnementales
finies et le besoin en même temps de
répondre aux injonctions des
consommateurs des industriels voilà
monsieur le président
merci Madame la rapporteur spécial pour
compléter les informations de la
commission je propose de
donner un temps de parole à la fois à
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire monsieur
Catteau puis à Madame alvax pour EDF
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur général
madame la rapporteur spéciale Mesdames
et Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs je voudrais tout
d'abord excuser le président de l'ASM
monsieur derosuc et son directeur
général monsieur gusta qui sont
actuellement à Vienne pour représenter
la France à la Convention sur la sûreté
nucléaire de la lieu de la IEA alors je
suis accompagné par Cyril Bernadet qui
est derrière moi qui dirige au centre de
la SN d'équipe des de spécialistes des
impacts du fonctionnement des centrales
nucléaires sur l'environnement alors de
manière générale je voudrais tout
d'abord indiquer que la SN partagent les
conclusions de la Cour des comptes en ce
qui concerne bien sûr les sujets sur
lesquels l'ASN et compétente ce rapport
est très et très complet il décrit de
manière claire les différents enjeux et
problématiques liés à l'adaptation du
parking nucléaire existant et futur au
changement climatique alors
j'articulaire j'articule aurait mon
propos introductif autour de trois
points
en premier lieu je souhaite revenir sur
les différentes conséquences du
changement climatique exposées par
Madame poder
conséquence d'une part sur la sûreté des
centrales nucléaires et d'autre part sur
l'impact de leur fonctionnement sur
l'environnement ça sera mon premier
point alors tout d'abord le surnom
climatique a des impacts sur la sûreté
des réacteurs alors par sûreté ce qu'on
entend c'est le risque de provoquer un
accident nucléaire alors comme ça a été
dit en particulier le changement
climatique modifie les aléas climatiques
susceptibles d'intervenir sur un site
dans le domaine de la Sûreté Nucléaire
on parle d'agression d'agression
climatique en l'occurrence c'est
notamment les risques de canicule de
tornades de tempête de fortes pluies
d'inondation de subversion marine ou
encore de périodes détachées sévère qui
peut priver la centrale de sa source de
refroidissement toutes ces toutes ces
agressions sont susceptibles de pouvoir
créer un accident nucléaire
donc comme c'est la été dit également
les centrales nucléaires sont
dimensionnés pour pouvoir faire face à
ce type d'événements et tous les 10 ans
ces agressions climatiques potentielles
sont réévaluées pour chaque site dans le
cadre du processus qu'on appelle
réexamen périodique qui est un exercice
donc décennale par exemple EDF est amené
à rehausser des digues par exemple sur
le site du Blayais sur le site de
Gravelines a renforcer la climatisation
de certains locaux industriel ou encore
à protéger certains structures des
effets d'une potentiel tornade donc là
on a un processus citératif tous les 10
ans qui quelque part est assez adapté à
un risque qui évolue et qui évolue dans
avec
une
dimension d'incertitude assez forte
d'ailleurs le régiment climatique
clairement complique ces projections il
ne s'agit pas simplement de regarder le
passé les événements du passé il s'agit
de d'estimer ce que peuvent être le ce
que peut-être le futur c'est un exercice
qui est d'une certaine façon plus
compliqué que de regarder d'autres
agressions par exemple comme le séisme
où il n'y a pas de raison que les
séismes du futur soit différent des
séismes du passé
alors dans une démarche de sûreté quand
il y a trop d'incertitudes en fait
le principe est de prendre des valeurs
pénalisantes donc de retenir des niveaux
d'aléas qui sont plus importants que que
ce que on pourrait on pourrait estimer
donc ces agressions climatiques sont en
particulier un sujet important du
quatrième règle des réacteurs donc c'est
ce règlement qui permet de franchir les
40 ans de fonctionnement c'est un sujet
qui revient très souvent en fait dans
les différentes démarches renforcer
d'associations du public que la SNM mène
dans le cas de ces examens périodiques
pour mémoire la SN consulte publique au
début de chaque examen périodique à sa
fin également elle consiste également le
public a ensuite si par site au cours du
règlement la SN participe à des
concertations particuliers ça par le
Haut Comité pour la transparence et
l'information sur la sûreté nucléaire
sur la sécurité du cas par exemple
pardon et la SN prend ensuite en compte
les conclusions des différentes enquêtes
publiques qui sont menées super site
donc voilà tout ça pour pour dire que ce
sujet de son climatique est clairement
un enjeu fort un enjeu fort à la fois de
transparence pour nous de pédagogie et
puis de prise en compte de ces retours
de public
par ailleurs sans attendre ces échéances
décennales la SN demande également à EDF
de prendre en compte tout événement
exceptionnel qui interviendrait donc ça
a été le cas en 99 après l'inondation du
site du Blayais ou encore après des
canicules de 2003 et 2006
le changement climatique a également des
conséquences sur l'impact occasionné par
la centrale nucléaire sur
l'environnement donc là on ne parle pas
de risque d'accident mais simplement de
fonctionnement de tous les jours
l'enjeu porte principalement comme ça a
été dit sur les centrales qui sont
refroidies par un cours d'eau et non
celle refroidie par la mer actuellement
certains acteurs puissent leur eau dans
la rivière et la restitue intégralement
cours d'eau à une température plus
élevée on parle là de 2 à 3 degrés plus
élevés ce qui peut avoir un impact sur
la faune et la flore aquatique les
autres centrales en Borderie rivière
sont conçues différemment elles
prélèvent moins d'eau et le la
refroidisse dans des tours aéros
réfrigérantes une partie de l'eau est
alors perdue dans l'atmosphère donc là
dans ce cas là on prélève moins d'eau
mais tout n'est pas restitué
et
l'échauffement est beaucoup plus faible
on parle on parle là de quelques
dixièmes de degré donc un impact sur la
faune et la flore aquatique qui est
beaucoup plus faible
justement afin de protéger cette faune
et cette flore la SN fixe pour chaque
centrale des valeurs maximales
d'échauffement du milieu naturel entre
la monde la centrale et l'aval de la
centrale que DF ne doit pas dépasser
alors le régiment climatique en ce qui
ne multiplie des cas desiages et de
température élevée des cours d'eau
conduit et rendre plus critique l'impact
des centrales nucléaires situés en bord
de rivière à la fois sur le plan de la
ressource en eau et sur celui de la
température du cours d'eau pour limiter
ces impacts sur environnement respecter
les limites de température fixées par la
SN EDF peut être amené à réduire la
puissance de ces réacteurs ou arrêter ou
à les arrêter en situation de canicule
ou des tiages alors ce signal toutefois
que en cas de besoin du réseau
électrique
l'édition de la SN permet d'augmenter
temporairement les limites de
température fixée la température de la
surveillance de l'environnement doit
alors être renforcée cette possibilité
d'augmenter temporairement les limites
de température résulte en fait d'un
retour d'expérience des canicules de
2003 et de 2006
alors je note à propos de ses limites
que la Cour recommande de consolider et
mettre à jour les fondations
scientifiques les justifiants
ces limites résulte en fait d'études
scientifiques qui permettent à aider de
constituer une étude d'impact propre à
chaque site mettre à jour ses limites à
la hausse si je comprends bien
l'orientation du rapport nesterait donc
que des constituent déjà une étude
d'impact une étude d'impact qui permet
de justifier l'acceptabilité pour le
milieu des nouvelles valeurs qui
seraient définies
alors j'ajoute que les périodes
d'etiages compliquent également
l'exploitation des centrales nucléaires
car limite des possibilités de procéder
au rejet des clients liquides
nécessaires à l'exploitation en effet
comme ça la
également été dit le fonctionnement des
centrales nucléaires produits en
permanence des effluents liquides qui
sont ensuite rejetés dans le cours d'eau
le début du cours d'eau affecte la
dispersion de ces effluents la scène a
donc fixé pour chaque centrale là aussi
une limite une limite de débit
minimale pour laquelle les rejets
déflions peuvent être réalisés en deçà
de cette limite c'est-à-dire en
situation d'etiale sévère les opérations
de rejet sont interdites et l'exploitant
doit en pro entreposer ses effluents sur
ce sujet la SN partage la recommandation
numéro 2 de la cour sur le besoin
d'adapter les capacités d'entreposage
avant rejet des effluents liquides l'été
dernier a montré que certaines capacités
d'EDF sont sous-estimées
enfin la température élevées de l'eau et
de l'air ont également un effet sur la
colon la colonisation par des
micro-organismes pathogènes les junelles
les amis dans les grandes tours
aérographies nucléaires le changement
climatique pourrait donc rendre les
traitements biocide chimiques des tours
plus fréquents et sur de plus grandes
périodes les rejets chimiques
correspondants sont ici aussi encadrés
par l'addition de l'ASM toutefois la
scène partage bien évidemment la
recommandation numéro 5 de la cour sur
le renforcement de la recherche de
développement sur des systèmes de
traitement biocytes plus sobre en
réactif chimique rejeté dans le milieu
naturel
j'en ai terminé pour mon premier point
qui était un peu long mais il me
semblait important de de replacer les
enjeux alors en deuxième point souhaite
indiquer que la SN partage le besoin
d'une approche systémique de
l'adaptation au changement climatique
des centrales nucléaires développés par
la Cour des comptes il faut clairement
sortir d'une approche critère par
critères qui ne permet pas d'appréhender
la démarche
d'adaptation dans sa globalité qui ne
permet pas d'en rendre compte de manière
transparente au public il me semble
également important de souligner que
l'adaptation sur moi climatique des
centrales nucléaires ne peuvent être
pensé sans une approche territoriale
intégratise et multis sectorielle mené
avec l'ensemble des acteurs ça la cour
là également dit cette vision collective
territoriale dépasse largement les
prérogatives restreintes restreinte à la
sûreté et à la protection de
l'environnement de l'ASM
cette approche
collective territorialisée et
particulièrement nécessaire en ce qui
concerne
l'impact cumulé des consommations d'eau
et des rejets radioactifs et chimiques
sur les centrales des bassins de la
Loire sur la Loire il y a 4 centrales
plus une sur un affluent donc ça fait 5
centrales sur sur le bassin et sur le
bassin du Rhône ou se situe 4 centrales
cette approche systémique est
territoriée du changement climatique est
également nécessaire lors du choix du
site d'un nouveau réacteur
il est toutefois à noter que le choix
d'un site dépend également d'autres
paramètres je parlais tout à l'heure de
des enjeux liés au séisme clairement la
sismicité d'un site est également un
sujet il y a également d'autres sujets
qui dépassent largement là aussi la
sûreté en tout état de cause le choix du
site est inscrit par la scène dans le
cadre de la procédure de demande
d'autorisation de création de chaque
nouvelle installation
si on arriverait à mon troisième et
dernier point qui concerne les
conséquences à anticiper des éventuelles
décisions qui concernent la future
politique énergétique et la durée de
fonctionnement envisageable du parc
nucléaire actuel
à la suite du rapport de RTE sur les
futurs énergétiques de la France à
l'horizon 2050 certains les scénarios
qui semblent être privilégiés par le
gouvernement prévoit la poursuite de
fonctionnement des réacteurs actuels
jusqu'à ou au-delà de 60 ans dès lors
que les conditions de sûreté le
permettraient
dans un tel contexte la SN a estimé qui
est nécessaire d'engager sans tarder des
réflexions avec EDF et l'IRSN sur les
déterminants de la poursuite
d'exploitation envisageable des
réacteurs en clair jusqu'à quand
pourrait-il fonctionner dans des
conditions de sûreté de protection de
l'environnement acceptable
en dépassant les le cadre formel des
examens périodiques décennaux en effet
le pas de sérexamen
des scénos n'est en effet pas adapté aux
besoins d'anticipation notamment pour la
tenue des composants
jugés irremplaçable ou difficilement
remplaçable des centrales nucléaires
dans cette réflexion que la SN souhaite
voir inscrite comme une obligation de
justification à fournir par EDF d'ici
fin 2026 dans la prochaine politique
pluriannuelle de l'énergie la SN a
demandé à EDF d'inclure la problématique
de l'adaptation sur mon climatique
directeur existants qui pourraient
fonctionner au-delà de 2050 c'est très
réflexion doit également intégrer les
effets du cumul avec les nouveaux
réacteurs de la construction pourrait
être décidé au bord des fleurs
l'été dernier a été marqué par des
phénomènes météorologiques extrêmes qui
montrent qu'une accélération des
phénomènes est une hypothèse qu'il ne
faut pas écarter pour un parc nucléaire
qui sera en extension dans les 20 à 30
prochaines années s'il en est décéder
ainsi il est donc nécessaire que des
spécialistes de la scène puisse inscrire
ces sujets pour pouvoir anticiper les
difficultés et que le gouvernement et le
Parlement puisse les prendre en compte
dans la politique énergétique les scènes
prévoit également là aussi de mener une
démarche d'associations publiques
renforcée sur ce sujet comme elle l'a
fait je l'ai mentionné pour le passage à
40 ans des réacteurs
voilà monsieur le Président je
maintiendrai je me tiendrai là à ses
propos liminaires
merci et pour terminer cette première
série de d'intervention de présentation
et d'analyse je vous propose d'écouter
Madame Catherine albac pour le compte de
EDF
excusez-moi monsieur le Président
Monsieur Elvis président madame la
sénatrice mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
mais Messieurs dames de la cour mes
collègues de la SN je vous remercie de
nous recevoir aujourd'hui et de pouvoir
vous présenter les les réflexions que
nous menons au sein du groupe EDF je
tiens d'abord à excuser monsieur Cédric
lemandeowski qui malheureusement est
mobilisé comme vous le savez aujourd'hui
par diverses problématiques qui ont été
rapidement évoqués tout à l'heure
nous je voudrais vous dire tout d'abord
que ce travail est un travail important
que nous avait que nous a été demandé et
que la Cour nous a demandé et dont je
tiens à préciser que des f partage la
majorité des recommandations et des
conclusions de ce travail qui est un
excellent travail y compris d'ailleurs
pour nous et nous aider à continuer dans
nos réflexions si j'aurai quelques
remarques préliminaires à faire c'est
d'abord le dérèglement climatique et
l'adaptation au changement climatique
concerne tout le monde et pas que le
parc nucléaire mais bien l'approche
systémique que la Cour a mis plusieurs
fois elle est majeure et pas uniquement
pour comme le disait monsieur Catteau
juste autour des sites mais parce
qu'elle embarque la totalité des
infrastructures indispensables à
l'activité d'une centrale nucléaire qui
sont par exemple les réseaux de
transport d'électricité mais aussi les
réseaux de télécom la disponibilité de
l'eau potable ça embarque bien sûr
toutes les infrastructures publiques
pour lesquelles il serait souhaitable
qu'un travail similaire soit conduit de
façon à ce que l'ensemble d'un
territoire puisse adapter nous
travaillons sur une démarche qui
s'appelle la préservation de
l'habitabilité des territoires et nous
inscrivons les centrales thermiques
qu'elles soient nucléaire ou à base de
gaz de choses qui produisent les gains à
effet de serre mais toutes les centrales
toutes les centrales de la dpnt sont
embarqués dans une démarche d'habilité
d'habitabilité des territoires et c'est
important parce que si on regarde la
problématique que vous avez largement
présenté de la disponibilité en eau la
disponibilité en eau est une
problématique qui touche aussi bien une
centrale thermique avec un combustible
nucléaire qu'une centrale thermique gaz
charbon ou fuel c'est-à-dire que dès que
nous nous adressons à de la production
pilotable il y a non pas pour la
uniquement pour la problématique de
sûreté mais essentiellement pour le
refroidissement de la partie électrique
c'est à la partie qui permet de produire
l'existence une nécessité de disposer
d'une source froide c'est donc un enjeu
majeur pour la nation qui va au-delà du
nucléaire le développement des énergies
renouvelables impose ce que nous ayons à
côté des énergies pilotables et cette
réflexion autour du pilotable et donc
une réflexion de système électrique pour
lequel le travail de la cour et
l'importance donné au caractère
systémique du dérèglement climatique et
aux caractères systémique de
l'adaptation et majeur
comme cela était présenté dans la
première slide vous avez vu quand même
que les incertitudes sont fortes bien
sûr nous avons le fait le choix chez EDF
de travailler sur un scénario médian qui
est celui dont nous rêvons tous si nous
relisons aujourd'hui les conclusions des
travaux du GIEC il nous disent atténuant
atténuant atténuant l'adaptation et
l'adaptateur et l'atténuation doivent
aller de paix c'est une réflexion
globale si nous ne voulons pas nous
retrouver dans des trajectoires
extraordinairement difficiles
c'est-à-dire un monde à 4 degrés et non
pas une France un 4 degrés c'est à dire
ce monde quasi invivable puisque ça nous
mettrait la France à peu près à 6 degrés
nous devons absolument réduire nos gaz à
effet de serre et dans ce cadre là le
nucléaire est une réponse parmi d'autres
pour décarboner l'électricité donc il
faut bien tenir les l'approche est
globale aussi bien en atténuation quand
adaptation et donc cette nécessité de
tenir compte des incertitudes que nous
avons nous la retrouvons dans les
travaux que nous menons bien sûr avec la
SN lorsque nous travaillons sur les
aléas sur la réflexion autour du
décamillénal mais il faut quand même
qu'on soit tous conscient qu'il n'y a
pas de retour à la normale possible nous
ne sommes pas dans une crise climatique
nous sommes dans une dérive climatique
c'est bien la raison pour laquelle
depuis
en gros deux en 2003 mais bien avant
déjà puisque le service climatique a été
créé enfin les premiers les embryons le
service climatique ont été créés dans
les années 90 nous avons tenu compte de
cette nécessaire incrémentation des
températures c'est à dire on ne revient
pas la normale et comme le dit fort bien
monsieur Pisani ferry dans une note que
je vous invite tous à relire dans la
mesure où le climat n'est plus stable
c'est-à-dire que la donnée économique
qui fonde notre économie qui se base sur
un climat stable celle-ci n'existe plus
et bien il va falloir comme vous l'aviez
dit fort bien il va falloir investir et
bien donc falloir mettre des CAPEX alors
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui ce que nous
mettons en matière d'adaptation peut
paraître peu importe mais on a aussi
joué la transparence puisque on a mis en
vous a présenté l'ensemble des choses
qui sont qui sont aujourd'hui engagés
mais je vous rassure ou je ne vous
rassure pas comme vous comme vous le
voulez malheureusement des
investissements importants arrivent
surtout si on demande demain aux
centrales nucléaires d'assurer la sûreté
la sécurité du réseau d'alimentation
donc des fournir quels choix les
conditions climatiques dans lequel elles
sont évidemment une centrale nucléaire
qui comme chez nos collègues américains
dit je ne suis plus dans des conditions
qui me permettent de produire j'assure
la sûreté mais je replie mes tranches
parce que débit des tiages parce que
température c'est une c'est une Centrale
qui va dire au réseau bah écoute je suis
dans la capacité de produire tu es
responsable de l'équilibre trouve une
solution en France on n'a pas on n'est
pas dans cette approche mais il est
clair que cette centrale nucléaire n'est
pas ne sera pas la même et vous avez
cité Palo VRD pas l'overdé est un
exemple nous avons énormément de
relations avec eux nous avons aussi des
liens avec baraka mais on voit que ce
type d'outils de production comme
d'ailleurs le fait le choix que va faire
la Californie pour maintenir un outil
spécifique pour le soutenir des réseaux
n'est pas le même qu'une centrale
classique qui est juste là pour produire
et émettre de la production sur les
marchés donc il y a une réalité vous
avez fort bien dit madame la sénatrice
il y a une réalité politique à intégrer
sur le système électrique et le rôle du
nucléaire de ce cadre-là je suis trop
bavarde monsieur le vice-président
surtout arrêtez moi
merci pour vous et beh du coup je passe
la parole merci à chacune à chacun
d'entre vous pour ces présentations et
du coup je passe la parole à notre
apporteur général que vous inspire c'est
présentation
au-delà des plantations monsieur le
Président je voulais d'abord remercier
la coupe pour la qualité de son rapport
et je partage la vie de la rapporteur
spécial
qui a souligné le fait qu'on est allé et
vous l'avez dit également dans le
présente au-delà des seuls éléments
comptables et financiers je pense que
c'est intéressant ça permet on l'a vu
dans d'autres rapports récemment commis
devant notre commission ça permet
finalement d'enrichir le débat et de lui
donner si j'utilise un terme donné de la
chair au-delà de la seule rigueur
comptable
je veux également remercier la SN et EDF
et puis peut-être aussi
Christine Labarde d'avoir
proposé ce rapport
puisque finalement il tombe à point
nommé et il met d'une certaine manière
l'accent au lendemain d'un nouveau
rapport du GIEC
sur
un choix que j'appellerais hasardeux
alors qui était malheureusement
fortement dans l'air du temps la
condamnation du nucléaire et de la
production d'électricité d'origine
nucléaire je pense et j'espère qu'on est
revenu dans
un temps qui doit nous permettre de
travailler avec eux plus d'objectivité
ce à quoi concourt
ce rapport alors
après ces quelques éléments de
présentation de contexte mais je crois
que notre commission est aussi un lieu
où on doit rappeler quelques
orientations fortes
et celle-ci me parait y répondre j'ai
trois ou quatre questions la première
vous avez établi ce rapport
avant qu'il ne soit question
dans le cadre d'une navette avec une
introduction nouvelle sur le projet
concernant les énergies renouvelables
d'une d'un projet de fusion entre la SN
est l'URSS
est-ce que ça peut
avoir des conséquences sur les
orientations notamment sur l'adaptation
du parc nucléaire au changement
climatique
autre élément on s'aperçoit
qu'aujourd'hui il est assez difficile
d'isoler les les dépenses qui portent
sur
l'adaptation du parc nucléaire au
changement climatique et notamment sur
le volet des investissements
est-ce que vous pensez qu'on peut
progresser sur le sujet et dans ce cas
là
quel selon vous quelles sont les
obstacles qu'il nous faudrait lever dans
votre rapport madame la Présidente vous
vous soulignez qu'il y a finalement une
démarche
normalisée et commune
sur
comment dirais-je un manque entre les
acteurs concernés pour adapter le parc
nucléaire au changement climatique
s'il y a des voies d'amélioration pour
mieux coordonner
quels sont-elles et éventuellement
est-ce que ça passe par la seule volonté
des acteurs ou est-ce qu'il faudrait
qu'il y ait une
jaillir une enceinte ou une structure
particulière soit existante soit
nouvelle même si je me méfie toujours de
ce qu'on ajoute un nouveau type puisque
ça ramène toujours une strat
supplémentaire enfin
en 2019
l'IRSN
abordait la question du risque desiages
notamment je crois qu'on y trouve un
écho avec les phénomènes de sécheresse
dont
les sécheresses de l'an passé qui qui
pourraient nécessiter des investigations
supplémentaires dans les travaux que
vous avez menés conduit est-ce que vous
avez pu peut-être
identifié
sur le sujet des des éléments nouveaux
ou y a-t-il encore des recherches à
faire dans cette perspective
merci monsieur le rapporteur général je
propose de prendre les questions de nos
collègues en complément des questions du
rapporteur général et ensuite nos
différents intervenants pourront
apporter les réponses à commencer par
Michel canvett qui sera suivi par Sylvie
ermédié merci monsieur le Président je
voudrais moi aussi remercier la cour
pour ce sujet extrêmement important on
le voit au niveau de l'actualité même si
dans le rapport du GIEC qui a été
produit avant-hier le nucléaire n'est
pas le plus vertueux puisque le plus
vertueux sont encore les énergies
renouvelables mais c'est un élément
indispensable à la stratégie de
production énergétique de notre pays et
je voulais demander
aux différents intervenants si à
l'instar de ce qui se passe pour les
déchets où il y a une incitation à
valoriser l'ensemble de l'énergie
produite est-ce que il en est de même
pour ce qui concerne le nucléaire
puisque l'un des points critiques c'est
le rejet de la chaleur de l'eau chaude
dans le milieu naturel est-ce que il n'y
a pas intérêt à valoriser celui-ci ou
est-ce
cela est déjà fait et puis je voulais
demander à Monsieur Catteau dans le
droit fil de l'intervention du
rapporteur général si la SN disposait
des compétences lui permettant de bien
analyser et la situation
ceci effectivement du fait du projet de
de regroupement de l'IRSN avec l'ASM
mais d'ores et déjà avez-vous les
compétences en la matière et puis
dernier point puisque monsieur Catteau a
également évoqué la prolongation de la
durée de vie des centrales à 60 ans
est-ce qu'il retient à pouvoir la porter
à 64 ans
merci merci Michel Sylvie
dedans donc je remercie moi aussi la
cour pour la présentation de ce rapport
et la réalisation ce rapport extrêmement
important extrêmement intéressant je
remercie aussi l'ensemble des
intervenants qui qui complètent cette
présentation j'aurais une question sur
les enjeux de la gestion de la ressource
en eau vous avez les uns ou les autres
parler des arbitrages qui PDF peut être
amené à faire concernant par exemple
soit la production hydraulique ou la
production nucléaire mais
la Cour a aussi évoqué la question des
autres enjeux peut-être plus en amont
sur des enjeux économiques divers
notamment par exemple la préservation de
site environnementaux ou la préservation
de la production agricole ou aussi par
exemple la préservation de l'économie
touristique
alors est-ce que il existe déjà des
réflexions sur des arbitrages qui
pourraient se faire euh de façon à bien
sûr protéger les centrales nucléaires
protéger la production
d'électricité mais est-ce que ça
pourrait aller jusqu'à
des arbitrages qui pourraient menacer la
production agricole ou les enjeux
touristiques ou même la préservation de
sites environnementaux est-ce qu'il y a
déjà des des arbitrages ou des
réflexions à ce niveau là merci
merci Sylvie Daniel 1er
merci je partage souvent des avis du
rapporteur et en l'occurrence je ne
partage pas son son point de vue même si
je reconnais au nucléaire le fait d'être
une énergie potentiellement des carbonée
mais qui a d'autres d'autres éléments
bon je voulais surtout remercier la cour
de d'être effectivement allé au-delà
d'éléments comptables et d'insister sur
les enjeux qu'il y a à se préparer au
futur et le futur étant la chose la plus
difficile à prévoir contrairement au
passé moi je voudrais savoir quels sont
les scénarios sur lesquels on travaille
quand on parle de centrales nucléaire à
venir des existantes qu'on pourrait
prolonger effectivement jusqu'à 64 ans
pour rester dans une norme très
française
malgré les les commentaires d'ailleurs
des créateurs de ces centrales et
l'accélération des des risques ou des
difficultés qu'on perçoit en tous les
cas je voudrais savoir quels sont les
hypothèses par exemple sur les niveaux
j'avais déposé un amendement qui a été
rejeté parce que satisfait où je
demandais que des études académiques
soient fournies systématiquement sur les
niveaux des tiages de l'eau imaginée à
échéance de 40 ans disons pour se
représenter donc j'aimerais savoir parce
que maintenant que le ministre BECHU
parle d'une France a plus 4 degrés ce
qui sort quand même de
on s'est raconté pendant des années
qu'on peut être on serait à plus un
ennemi ou plus d'eux bon je pense qu'il
est quand même plus sage et surtout
quand on parle de sûreté de regarder une
France à plus 4 degrés qui par ailleurs
devient peut-être pas le scénario du
pire mais un scénario assez probable
donc je voulais savoir quels étaient les
hypothèses que vous aviez pris un
deuxième remarque c'est sur le risque de
submersion que j'ai vu que l'amendement
de ma collègue avait sauté à l'Assemblée
nationale si j'ai bien compris Christine
évoque le fait que Christine Navarre
porteur évoque le fait que ce risque est
maîtrisé je voulais juste rappeler
kushima il a été maîtrisé jusqu'au
moment où au fond l'événement a dépassé
ce qui était programmé donc je non mais
on a quand même on est excusez-moi on
est passé quand même en 99 à deux doigts
d'une catastrophe en France par ce
risque submersion je sais qu'on a pris
des mesures complémentaires il n'empêche
là aussi moi j'aimerais comprendre quand
on regarde les trajectoires que le GIEC
indique comme possible et qui de rapport
aura en rapport augmente j'aimerais
savoir au fond quelles sont les niveaux
qui nous garantissent réellement en
termes de sécurité tant pour la
submersion le risque du niveau des
tâches des fleuves me paraît moins grave
il me paraît plus grave peut-être sur la
production mais moins grave sur la
sûreté et puis dernière remarque un tout
toute petite pique
moi je défends qu'il faut garder une
dualité des expertises IRSN ASN et je
voulais questionner le représentant de
la SN pour savoir combien de fois cet
été nous avons dérogé aux règles de
préservation des milieux et de la
biodiversité et nous interroger
collectivement chers collègues à chaque
fois que l'été il y aura arbitrer entre
la préservation de la biodiversité des
fleuves et la préservation de la
fourniture en électricité à votre avis à
notre avis partager quel sera l'élément
qui sera central dans la décision
merci Daniel Christian Billac pour
terminer la série de questions
merci prudent et puis merci à la cour
merci madame la Présidente merci EDF et
merci à la chaîne pour ces informations
une remarque préalable moi je crois que
on ne peut pas se passer du Leclerc il
faut le dire c'est indispensable parce
que
de la dépendance indépendance
énergétique et aussi parce que c'est une
énergie décarbonée et que l'effet de
serre doit être combattu et puis aussi
parce qu'on a une hausse de consommation
électrique qui est inéluctable encore un
autre jour ici on recevait
une réunion consacrée aux crypto actifs
et on a vu la consommation énergétique
de ces jeux changent financiers plus
loin artificiel mais qui au niveau de la
consommation électrique ne sont pas du
tout artificielles sont bien réels donc
voilà mais je crois que le tout
nucléaire
ça serait une erreur et c'est pourquoi
je pense que
le mix énergétique et la solution le mix
énergétique et comme on dit dans nos
campagnes il faut pas mettre tous les
jeux dans le même panier et donc avoir
plusieurs sources et j'en viens à ma
question madame la Présidente a parlé de
complémentarité entre l'hydraulique et
les centrales nucléaires et moi je me
demande si cette complémentarité et les
judicieux pardonnez-moi madame la
présente parce que l'hydraulique les
barrages en général c'est l'été qu'on a
les étiages et les problèmes de
refroidissement et c'est l'été qu'on a
aussi les etiaces dans les barrages donc
là il y a ça me tient par contre la
nature fait bien les choses c'est l'été
déjà qu'on consomme moins d'énergie que
l'hiver et c'est l'été
qu'on a du soleil
et donc moi ma question c'est est-ce que
nos complémentarité entre l'énergie
solaire et l'énergie nucléaire est
possible et est-ce que cette perte de
production que sommes tout à fait
faibles avez-vous solide dans votre
rapport là
pourraient être compensée éventuellement
par une production d'énergie solaire
photovoltaïque est-ce que c'est réaliste
est-ce que ce n'est pas avant nous les
capacités voilà c'est à dire le absorber
parce que je crois que ça se fait une
erreur de déroger sans cesse plus loin
avec le réchauffement des cours d'eau
par les rejets le refroidissement des
central est-ce que le solaire peut nous
permettre d'avoir une sécurité nucléaire
une sécurité de nos cours d'eau et de la
biodiversité et de l'énergie pour pour
les Français
merci merci Christian donc je vous
propose qu'on passe la parole aux
intervenants pour apporter des réponses
selon une méthode chère à nos présidents
rénale nous pourrions commencer par la
dernière personne qui s'est exprimée
tout à l'heure et je vous demande s'il
vous plaît de le faire dans un temps
contraint parce qu'ensuite il y aura la
conclusion de notre apporteur spécial il
faut qu'on a impérativement fini pour
16h donc si vous pouviez nous faire ces
réponses
efficaces en deux ou trois minutes ce
serait parfait
sur l'incitation la valorisation de
l'ensemble de l'énergie produite il y a
pas aujourd'hui spécifiquement
d'incitation il y a beaucoup d'exemples
qui existent par exemple la Gravelines
on a on a une production importante de
de
bars et de sol qui est souvent méconnu
c'est la plus grande
production de poisson qui alimentait
largement par les les eaux de la
centrale l'eau chaude de la centrale
mais il y a pas aujourd'hui de
d'incitation majeures mais on y
retravaille la vraie question est plutôt
d'arriver à trouver des productions qui
peuvent accepter que dans certains cas
on est des arrêts de tranches et que
donc la chaleur fatale ne soit pas
disponible donc il faut qu'on
réfléchisse il y a les les c'est plus
les crocodiles maintenant c'est c'est le
centre des dinosaures il y a mais il y a
aussi des il y avait des crocodiles mais
ils sont toujours là mais voilà il faut
qu'on trouve des solutions qui
permettent d'avoir des productions mais
il y a beaucoup de choses qui sont en
train de s'installer en particulier en
maraîchage à Saint-Laurent ça c'est pour
la alors sur la question de la ressource
en eau et des arbitrages entre
l'environnement l'agriculture et
l'économie touristique
aujourd'hui on a nous une démarche en
matière environnementale très très forte
et on a énormément de projets qui sont
là pour préserver la biodiversité dans
les budgets qui ont été présentés on n'a
pas présenté les 7 millions d'euros
annuels qui sont consacrés tous les ans
pour la les tous les travaux en matière
de recherche développement autour de la
biodiversité on a rien qu'autour de la
problématique de nos centrales un projet
qui s'appelle thermidrobiaux qui suit
les populations de poissons depuis des
années c'est certainement la plus grande
séquence de suivi biologiques
actuellement disponible en France les
travaux sont publics et qui montrent
aujourd'hui que nous n'avons pas
d'impact majeur même pas d'impact des
centrales nucléaires et que la
problématique aujourd'hui pour les
populations de poissons c'est bien le
réchauffement global bien avant la bien
avant l'impact des centrales tout est
tout est disponible et nous sommes
convaincus qu'il faut travailler sur un
projet global qui permet de préserver
aussi bien la production d'électricité
que l'agriculture effectivement
effectivement comme ça a été dit par par
un une autre personne il y a une
production différente en été en hiver et
bien sûr qu'un mètre cube d'eau prélevé
en hiver n'a pas la même valeur qu'un
mètre cube d'eau prélevé en été en
situation des tirages donc effectivement
l'agriculture a un positionnement
différent du nôtre donc on doit pouvoir
arriver à gérer les problématiques mais
ça passe par le renforcement de la
protection de l'environnement il n'y a
pas de d'avenir si nous ne protègeons
pas le grand cycle de l'eau si nous ne
permettons pas la percolation des eaux
si nous ne protègeons pas les zones
naturelles en amont et on a au niveau de
DF on sera ravi de vous le présenter un
énorme travail là dessus aussi bien
autour des barrages qu'autour des
centrales et même au-delà de nos
centrales aujourd'hui pour protéger les
zones humides et préserver dans le grand
cycle de l'eau si je j'ai pris quelques
notes alors les scénarios sur lequel on
travaille alors comme ça a été présenté
dans la première slide on travaille sur
toute une série de scénarios et il faut
faire la différence entre les scénarios
du GIEC et le modèle climatique il y a
aujourd'hui une quarantaine de modèles
climatiques ont été développés par
toutes les équipes scientifiques dans le
monde et nous testons au moins 20
modèles qui ressemble le plus au modèle
des climats qu'on pourrait trouver en
France et donc à chaque scénario du GIEC
nous nous appliquons une vingtaine de
modèles climatiques différents pour
essayer d'imaginer au mieux le climat du
territoire demain il y a énormément de
questions aujourd'hui les modèles ne
sont pas parfaits et donc on a on
travaille systématiquement sur les
scénarios les plus pénalisants du GIEC à
différentes échéances 2030 2050 2100 et
nous travaillons là sur plusieurs
modèles aussi climatiques comme je vous
l'ai dit il y a évidemment un très beau
débat sur la problématique des
précipitations vous savez qu'aujourd'hui
aucun modèle ne donne autant les
trajectoires de température sont assez
bien cernés autant le problème des
précipitations est très variable nous
avons des modèles qui nous disent qu'il
va pleuvoir plus il y a des modèles qui
nous disent qu'il va pleuvoir moins il y
a des celles qui nous disent que ça sera
différent entre l'été et l'hiver il y a
une foule de modèle différent mais en
matière de précipitation aujourd'hui on
n'a pas vraiment de donner scientifiques
qui permettent de dire le l'avenir du
climat c'est comme ça ce qui pose
évidemment derrière le problème de
simuler les étiages sévèrement c'est une
vraie question et ça pose bien sûr toute
une série de verrous scientifiques qui
doivent encore être levés pour qu'on
puisse travailler sur comment le l'eau
va se positionner ce qu'on peut se dire
quand même c'est que globalement cette
tendance aux grands anti-clones qu'on a
vécu depuis plusieurs années
particulièrement cet hiver montre que
l'anticyclone des Açores a tendance à
remonter vers le nord on s'oriente vers
un climat qui ressemble donc un petit
peu à celui de la de l'Espagne en tout
cas pour le sud de la Loire ce qui veut
dire effectivement des plutôt des
précipitations hivernales et très peu de
précipitations en été c'est ce qu'on vit
c'est une tendance qu'on voit pour
autant cette tendance ne peut pas être
aujourd'hui totalement certifiée par la
science et des tendances météo qu'on
voit mais aujourd'hui on peut pas dire
c'est vraiment le dérèglement climatique
pour autant c'est quand même ce qu'on
vit en gros depuis 2015 voilà voilà
j'essaye d'aller vite vous m'avez dit 5
minutes je dépasse un petit peu mais je
vais faire mieux alors
je laisserai mon collègue pour se
positionner sur la dualité asnirsn et
combien de fois nous avons dérogé cet
été mais si j'ai tous les éléments si
vous en avez besoin
et puis alors sur la complémentarité
hydraulique et centrale nucléaire il
faut bien comprendre que nos Grands
Anciens ont fait un choix dès l'origine
qui est le choix qui nous a permis
d'avoir certainement le système
électrique aujourd'hui le plat résilient
et l'électricité pendant très longtemps
la moins chère d'Europe le modèle le
électrique français a été de dire que
l'hydraulique et le nucléaire ont été
imaginés ensemble donc on peut
évidemment faire évoluer le mix
énergétique comment le souhaite mais à
l'origine les les équipes de Marcel
Boiteux et et les grands ministres qui
ont présidé à la mise en place du parc
nucléaire ont résonné hydraulique et
nucléaire de façon conjointe on voit
aussi que dans la plupart des pays qui
aujourd'hui ont un très fort
développement du mix énergétique
nucléaire cette démarche est reprise et
donc on voit quand même qu'il y a une
cohérence même si bien sûr ça n'exclut
pas un travail sur le soleil
photovoltaïque sachant quand même sans
vouloir taquiner le soleil on en produit
pas la nuit mais néanmoins il y a bien
sûr une démarche intéressante autour du
soleil qui qui doit absolument être
développé le maintien du nucléaire
n'exclut évidemment pas le nom
développement bien au contraire des
énergies renouvelables
merci beaucoup monsieur Catteau
oui alors il y avait une question sur
les compétences de la SN en la matière
je pense que la SN souffre comme comme
beaucoup et comme je l'ai exposé de la
sectorisation qui existe ou qui existait
jusqu'à présent dans le domaine donc
nous avons évidemment des spécialistes
des agressions climatiques nous avons
évidemment des spécialistes de la
protection de l'environnement ce qui
nous manque c'est voilà c'est encore une
fois c'est peut-être cette vision
intégrative intégratrice alors un
problème de compétence ou d'organisation
je ne sais pas vous dire actuellement en
tout cas c'est un sujet qui est bien
identifié et qui a largement été mis en
lumière également pour par le rapport de
la Cour
sur les hypothèses prises en compte pour
définir les niveaux desiages dans dans
la démonstration de sûreté des réacteurs
en fait le retour d'expérience montre
que il y a pas vraiment de sujets n'a
pas vraiment un impact
des étages que vous qu'on vit en ce
moment n'ont pas vraiment un impact
direct sur la sûreté des réacteurs on
est très loin des niveaux qui sont pris
en compte et niveau minimum qui sont
pris en compte ces niveaux minimaux ils
sont ils sont définis sur la base du
retour expense auquel on rajoute des
marges des marges qui sont assez
importantes l'impact des états et encore
une fois pas sur le risque accidentel il
est plutôt sur l'impact sur
l'environnement en fait l'environnement
l'impact de la centrale sur
l'environnement
en ce qui concerne le risque de
submersion donc sur cerise submersion la
SN a publié un guide un guide qui
concerne en fait tous les risques
d'inondation des signes nucléaires
ce risque est pris en compte en
regardant la probabilité de
d'avoir une
chaque type d'inondation on parle là sur
plutôt des retours des paires de retour
de 1000 ans auxquels là aussi on rajoute
des marges
on prend en compte notamment
la marelle la plus importante une
surcote liée à un grand vent voilà donc
on empile en fait dans ces démarches des
marges et ça peut conduire ça peut
conduire éventuellement à renforcer des
digues donc là il y a des travaux en
cours notamment à Gravelines et au
Blayais
par ailleurs il y a toujours la
possibilité qu'un événement vraiment
exceptionnel dépasse les valeurs prises
dans ce cas là les gérer les moyens qui
ont été ajoutés sur chaque site
nucléaire à la suite de l'accident de
Fukushima apporte une réponse
c'est l'idée du ce qu'on a appelé le
noyau dur donc c'est des des dispositifs
qui qui permettent d'aller au-delà de
niveau pour lequel la centrale est
dimensionnée ça apporte de la résilience
des moyens à la fois globalement pour
ajouter et pour amener de l'eau de
l'électricité ce sont des les éléments
essentiels pour ensuite pouvoir gérer
une crise nucléaire
et puis et puis je mentionne que ces
niveaux ils sont comme je l'ai dit
réévaluer tous les 10 ans tous les 10
ans on s'adapte à l'évolution des
connaissances
voilà sur la réforme du contrôle
permettrait de ne pas répondre
précisément mais évidemment qu'une
réforme du contrôle elle doit prendre en
compte l'ensemble des missions de
l'instance de contrôle et ces missions
elles doivent être assurées dans la
durée voilà je pense que il y avait pas
d'ambiguïté ni dans les ni dans la
situation actuelle ni dans le projet qui
est qui a été mis sur la table par le
gouvernement
merci Monsieur le Directeur madame la
Présidente
je vais me permettre de répondre très
brièvement en trois points sur la
méthode sur les arbitrages et sur les
dérogations apportées je vais commencer
par là parce que je pensais que Monsieur
Catteau aurait peut-être répondu mais
c'est très simple il y a eu 5
dérogations apportées sur 5 centrales au
cours de l'été entre mi-juillet le 11
septembre sur les centrales sont
surprises dites thermosensible budget
Blayais Saint-Alban Golfech Tricastin
que j'ai cité d'ailleurs dans mon
diaporama et je rassure tout le monde ça
a été une utilisation effective sur des
très courtes durées donc il y a pas lieu
d'affoler non plus sur les dérogations
consenties à l'application des normes
environnementales sur la méthode
maintenant deux points comment
identifier pour répondre rapporteur
général les investissements et qui
relèveraient du changement climatique
écoutez la comptabilité c'est un
ensemble de conventions
la comptabilité analytique ça permet de
taguer des dépenses et de les identifier
je pense qu'aujourd'hui compte tenu des
préoccupations environnementales qui se
font chaud toutes grandes entreprises
qu'elle soit publique ou privée se doit
dans l'exercice de sa responsabilité à
environnementale et social et dans
l'exercice de sa responsabilité en
termes de communication extra-financière
d'identifier les investissements j'ai
été rassuré parce que la représentante
des DF disait les investissements sont
devant nous donc pour l'instant
effectivement ça a été un peu infime
mais je crois que là il faut avoir un
peu de volontarisme compte tenu de
l'ambition que porte l'exploitant sur le
parc existant et sur le parc à venir sur
les questions de structure je me
limiterai à dire que la Cour a produit
des rapport en 2018 sur la SN en 2021
sur l'IRSN ces rapports sont disponibles
ils ont pu être communiqués au Sénat
parce qu'on est communique au Parlement
même s'ils ne sont pas publiques je
précise bien et en tout cas il nous
semble nous que c'est pas tant une
affaire de structure mais quand on parle
d'approche systémique c'est la capacité
des acteurs à se parler à utiliser le
même vocabulaire et surtout à définir
des méthodes communes que ce soit dans
les grands principes à les soins
national ou que ce soit dans la
déclinaison à l'échelot local mais
monsieur Catteau tout à l'heure a donné
des illustrations dans son exposé qui
permet d'être confiant sur notre
capacité à mais c'est souvent la
difficulté on préconise toujours une
nouvelle structure mais finalement c'est
tout simplement l'art de pouvoir se
parler et de pouvoir échanger en toute
franchise aujourd'hui les rôles clair
l'IRSN un rôle d'expertise elle rend ses
avis publics c'est totalement
transparent et l'ASN sur la base de ses
avis prend des décisions voilà la Cour
ne peut pas en dire plus parce que là
n'a pas écrit plus c'est tout simple sur
les arbitrages maintenant alors sur les
arbitrages entre l'hydraulique et
le nucléaire sur un même cours d'eau bon
on est très conscient ces questions
alors il s'avère je ne fais pas je ne
dévoile pas un scoop notre premier
président a annoncé un rapport public
annuel sur l'adaptation au changement
climatique en 2024 et c'est une
problématique qui sera abordée dans le
cadre de ce rapport sur les arbitrages
maintenant avec les autres
usages là aussi on vient de sortir un
rapport public annuel notamment sur la
politique de l'eau qui annonce un
rapport approfondi sur la gestion
quantitative de l'eau je ne peut pas en
dire plus ça sortira dans les prochains
mois et les sujets seront très
clairement abordés et voilà j'ai répondu
je pense à l'essentiel des questions
merci merci beaucoup et pour conclure
cette commission donc je passe la parole
à notre apport spécial Christine
Christine Lavarde merci monsieur le
Président alors moi je n'ai pas formulé
de proposition
complémentaires aux recommandations de
la Cour des comptes donc ce que je vous
propose c'est d'adopter enfin
d'autoriser la publication du rapport de
la Cour en fait avec mes propos
liminaires parce que
merci beaucoup bah du coup oui je
propose de la commission d'autoriser la
publication de l'enquête de la Cour des
comptes en annexe du rapport
d'information de notre collègue
rapporteur spécial tout le monde est
David l'autorisé je vous en remercie et
du coup je vous remercie vraiment madame
la présidente Madame la Directrice
monsieur le directeur ainsi que les
équipes qui vous accompagnent pour à la
fois le travail le travail important qui
a été mené et puis l'ensemble de vos
interventions qui sont venus éclairer la
commission des finances sur ce sujet
très important merci à notre rapporteur
spécial merci beaucoup